ce document la preuve du paiement de
l'impôt à sept maris en 2016 c'est ivre
en bon et samaritain pure souche son
intention affirmé est d'être candidat à
l'élection municipale de saint paris qui
a lieu le 26 novembre prochain
hier en allant déposer sa liste à la
sous-préfecture de trinité quelle ne fut
pas sa surprise
le service élections lui signifie son
inégibilité sans que ce refus
d'inscription ne soit formellement
motivés ils savaient encore du jour le 2
mai le 6 au soir
j'étais sur ma page impots.gouv.fr
possible à cette marie a faussé jacques
le lendemain à 12h30
tout allait changer est imposable à au
marteau parce que à partir du 27 janvier
j'ai déménagé j'ai fait mon changement
d'alès le 23 janvier à aux impôts de
trinité la date limite de dépôt de
candidature était prévue à 18 heures ce
jour dans l'après midi il introduit un
référé auprès du tribunal administratif
avec constat d'huissier normalement je
devais payer je dois payer mais mon
épaule à cette fin et donc je suis
toujours éligible donc je ne comprends
pas ce qui se passe j c'est de chercher
j'ai appelé impôts kg selon l'hôpital
alors elle ne leur a pas été possible de
me répondre
il y a eu un problème ils sont allés
jusqu'à me dit bon vous étiez imposé
comme ça vous n'avez pas de droit vous
habitiez c'est dans la norme de clown à
palalda et chaque année je recevais une
venelle des positions où on entre sites
inscrits
quoi qu'il en soit saint-yves rangoon
désarme pas sa liste sera tout de même
présenté ce samedi sans qu'ils n'en
fassent nécessairement partie demain on
sera probablement si la requête de
scintilleront a abouti